Lo que vamos a hacer en este video será practicar
la suma de números de varias cifras o dígitos,
pero el objetivo no es encontrar el resultado sino
comprender por qué funciona el método que usamos.
Tenemos 40,762 + 30,473. Si quieren pueden pausar
el video y tratar de resolverlo por su cuenta,
pero en este caso quiero que vean primero el video
para comprender cómo funciona este método. Vamos a
pensar en esto en términos de su valor posicional.
Esta cantidad llega a la posición de las decenas
de millar, así que tenemos decenas de millar,
millares, centenas, decenas y unidades. Hacemos
una pequeña tabla aquí y vamos a expresar cada uno
de estos números en decenas de millar, millares,
centenas, decenas y unidades. Al mismo tiempo
vamos a usar el método tradicional o algoritmo
estándar. Algoritmo es una palabra elegante para
referirnos a un sistema o una forma de resolver
algo. Primero expresemos estos números en las
columnas: aquí tenemos 4 decenas de millar, en
esta la ponemos: 1, 2, 3, 4; en este otro número
tenemos 3 decenas de millar: 1, 2, 3; después
vamos a sumar lo que hay en esta columna, en ambos
números tengo 0 millares, así que dejamos vacía
esta columna; aquí tenemos 7 centenas: 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6 y 7; y en este número tenemos 4 centenas: 1,
2, 3 y 4; pasamos a la columna de las decenas y en
este número tenemos 6 decenas: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 y 6;
y en este otro número tenemos 7 decenas: 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6 y 7; finalmente aquí tenemos 2 unidades:
1, 2, y aquí 3 unidades: 1, 2 y 3. Vamos
a reescribir de nuevo este número de acá:
tenemos 4 decenas de millar y 0 millares, 40,000,
luego tenemos 7 centenas, lo escribimos, tenemos
6 decenas y finalmente 2 unidades. Simplemente
estoy volviendo a escribir el número, pero con
el color que representa cada valor posicional.
Esto y esto otro son dos formas de representar
el mismo número. Reescribimos también este
número de acá: 3 decenas de millar y 0 millares,
luego tenemos 4 centenas, después tenemos 7
decenas y finalmente 3 unidades. Ahora vamos a
sumar lo que tenemos aquí y también vamos a sumar
lo que tenemos acá. Normalmente comenzamos en la
posición de menor valor: 2 unidades más 3 unidades
son 5 unidades, de forma similar 2 unidades más 3
unidades son 1, 2, 3, 4 y 5 unidades. Vamos bien.
Veamos la posición de las decenas; en la posición
de las decenas tenemos 6 decenas más 7 decenas.
Normalmente decimos que tenemos 13 decenas, pero
13 decenas es lo mismo que 3 decenas y 1 centena,
así que lo que hacemos es reagrupar: ponemos aquí
las 3 decenas y acá ponemos la centena. A veces
las personas dicen que llevan un 1, ponemos el 3
y llevamos un 1, que ponemos aquí. Parece magia,
pero lo que hacemos es tomar 10 decenas y las
reagrupamos en la posición de las centenas. Aquí
se verá más claramente: tenemos 6 decenas más 7
decenas, las sumamos y tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 y 13 decenas. Lo que hacemos
aquí es ver que todo esto nos da 1 centena y
3 decenas, por lo que ponemos aquí la centena
y escribimos el 3 en las decenas. ¿Qué tenemos en
la posición de las centenas? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11 y 12, lo escribimos aquí abajo: 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11 y 12. Aquí sucede
lo mismo que en las decenas, no tenemos un dígito
que represente el 12 en nuestro sistema numérico,
así que tomamos 10 de estos y los convertimos en
1 millar, que pondremos en esta columna. Y ahora,
de este lado hacemos lo mismo: 1 + 7 + 4 es 12,
son 12 centenas, ponemos 2 centenas más 1 millar;
en la posición de los millares tenemos 1 + 0 = 1,
igual de este lado tenemos 1 millar; finalmente
en la posición de las decenas de millar, 4 decenas
de millar más 3 decenas de millar nos da 7 decenas
de millar; lo mismo pasa de este lado: 4 + 3
nos da 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 y 7 decenas de millar,
el resultado es 71,235, lo mismo queda de este
lado 71,235. Espero que con esto hayan comprendido
mejor cómo estas dos representaciones funcionan.
No es que mágicamente llevemos números de un
lado a otro, sino que representamos los mismos
números de distintas formas. Con esto terminamos.